so here we are I am talking to my good
friend Tetsu Tetsu Young who is in
Montreal and we are close friends
because we every year until this year
we've worked together on the long fest
and I had a question from Ryan Jorgensen
here and said Steve we're expecting our
first child I want to bring my child I
don't know it's a boy or girl up
bilingual have you any suggestions and I
was very unsuccessful in getting our
kids to learn languages so I said I will
turn to the person who knows all about
raising children who speak two or more
languages so Tetsu nice to see you and
we're gonna talk about that and we're
also going to introduce your channel
which is ask Tetsu and maybe you could
briefly introduce yourself and what you
have done particularly to make your kids
so wonderfully multilingual well thank
you Steve for the for the great
introduction so my name is Tetsu young
and I run a channel called ask Tetsu so
definitely you know your viewers can can
ask me any question they I'll leave a
link in the description box too
fantastic fantastic and I have four
children
my oldest Roni is almost turning eight
now and then I have Nica who's six akela
who's three and we just had a fourth one
in a translation thank you thank you and
all four of our children are being
raised in five languages that's English
French Japanese Mandarin and Spanish and
these happen to be the same five I say
that I you know consider myself fluent
in I grew up in in Taiwan to Taiwanese
father and a Japanese mother and they've
always you know created an environment
for me to be you know to learn many
different languages not through drills
and schooling and whatnot but really
trick creating an environment where I
would learn languages naturally so I've
taken that same mindset you know that's
worked well through throughout the
decades just doing the same thing with a
modern twist and for my children and so
far it's working working so you know
working pretty well I think
they're all my kids have an age
standardized level and I would say you
know at least three of the the five
languages and the other two are pretty
okay and so and but of course you know
your native level in English so how did
you get from growing up in Taiwan maybe
a little bit of background how did you
guess from growing up in Taiwan and you
had parents that spoke those two
languages so presumably you became
fluent in those two languages at home
but what's the rest of your story so all
right grew up in Taiwan but actually I
was actually born in Hong Kong because
my parents weren't made in Hong Kong but
we the whole family went back to Taiwan
before I was one-year-old so essentially
I say I'm from Taiwan and what happened
is speaking Mandarin with my father all
the time and Japanese with my mother
that obviously that creates two very
strong languages since birth and also in
Taiwan as you know there's Taiwanese and
Hakka which are you know other languages
in Taiwan that's that's very well spread
and and then my parents sent me to an
American school when I was six so that
that's where Englishman meant so English
is my strongest language but I never say
it's my first language because
chronologically speaking it's not my
first engine but because you because you
study and you work in it and write yes
well I've been essentially I've been
educated in English you know with with a
few years here and there in French when
I was in being so that's once man
so Mandarin Mandarin Japanese Hakka
Taiwanese in English while I was in
Taiwan then my parents decided to send
me to Quebec after elementary school Wow
so that's where French comes in because
you know they said my father has a
younger sister so that's my aunt who
have I had never met before married to
Quebec or so I came to Quebec for my
high school that's when French came in
whereabouts a little piece so it's just
outside of Montreal there's a little
little town called okay yeah yeah
just off the island coffee there you go
so that's that's where I started my
Canadian journey which continues to
today yeah you know just out of
curiosity you arrived at this High
School in Vigo with zero French yeah
zero French they're the first days I
remember it's every every question that
was directed my mouth my way I had a
50-50 chance of answering right you know
it's we know but you know I'm stuck when
they ask me how old I am and how long
before you were able to function ah so
this is this is a very interesting thing
yeah I don't know why but I was able to
pick it up quite quickly you're what 12
13 13 yes I was 13 when I came and I
don't recall being you know
dysfunctional for a very long time and
you weren't in a special glass for
immigrant children or anything else you
were right in there with everyone as a
matter of fact yeah they decided to put
me in the trilingual group the highest
level in that writer which is English
French bilingual plus Latin but that was
that was how I started and there's a
test at the end of the first year or so
there's secondary one two three four
five four secondary one two and three if
you have an average of 70 70 or 75
percent across all your subjects you can
be exempted from the last final exams so
everybody works hard for that and I've
worked hard definitely for that but I
was not expecting to get it right here
in fact my parents were expecting me to
redo given the language barriers but I
don't I was just so motivated not so
much fun when I came right now with with
winter sports and and just you know
being in Canada so it's an all-around
fun thing that got me and there were no
other there were no other Chinese
speakers or Japanese speakers in the
school no there was one Japanese at my
school that I know ruff I did not know I
came into secondary Ronnie
in secondary too so he was late I yeah
up there and I never talked to him
alright so hey I think that's very
interesting because you naturally
learned without I mean obviously you
have French as a subject at the school
but you learned much more quickly than
that you learned by interacting with
other people that's right so I wouldn't
say I learned French as a site now I
learned infra write everything
everything and the French language part
per se is really upon arrival you know
with my cousin's right just trying to
figure it out with English and Fries
just slowly you know rye tipping the
balance towards French and it's a matter
of months yeah I mean I had the same
experience coming to Canada from Sweden
and of course I was much younger I was
five but I have no recollection of ever
having any difficulty in communicating I
don't know when I'm sort of morphed from
being a Swedish speaker to an English
speaker quickly forgot my Swedish which
is not your case and everything was in
English that was that I sometimes think
by putting kids in these ESL classes
today they handicap them but I guess
they got so many of the INA it's it's a
difficult situation I agree so now let's
move from that to your kids so know I
should confess first of all that my wife
and I tried everything to get the kids
to learn languages our focus was French
first of all no we put them into a but
we're living in Japan we put them in
Japanese yochien' which wasn't very
successful because the Buddhist priests
kept on hitting them over the head when
they weren't sitting straight sunako
opinion bah they didn't like the
cultural shark that they got there and
then we put them in to a bilingual
school in Ottawa when we were living
there sent them to French summer camp
and nothing but resistance and in the
end I gave up so how what did we do
wrong and what what did you do right
well I don't know if you did anything
wrong I'm sort of wondering what would
happen so in Japan if you're yeah oh
they were you know whatever yochi n35
said something like that they wore these
goofy hats and and be they resist it
they didn't like it I mean that was less
of an issue
the age was an issue that was not an
issue like and they played soccer with
Japanese kids although they were teased
as being foreign kids but no I think if
we had stuck with it if we had stayed in
Japan and they had stayed with that that
would have worked that's that when then
they ended up going to no we did stay in
Japan then we went to the you know sink
what does it call they can't remember
the school and Tokyo run by their Creek
Quebec fathers their st. Mary's Mary
okay yes so then their education was in
English but then it was more the French
effort that failed you know the Japanese
effort was very early on and we moved
back to Canada so that was that but so
how do you approach this like I have
heard stories of people trying to get
the kids to learn a language I mean I
can remember when with my parents that
tried to say we're gonna speak French
around the dinner table and that lasted
for about three minutes and then we
revert back to English I think there are
a lot of people who have been
unsuccessful in getting their kids to
learn languages so what did you do that
was successful I focus on taking away as
much of the learning language this
active learning part and if I focus a
lot on creating the environment right
where they need to do to speak that
language where they need to interact
with people who speak that language so
it's really a matter of making it useful
for AI and making it making it you you
know easier for you as a parent also to
create a habit to speak a specific
language with the kids so I speak you
know even though I speak these languages
I only speak one language with the kids
and that's Mandarin and that's expand I
do that exclusively when I say
exclusively it means all the
interactions meaningful interactions
that I have with my kids are in Mandarin
so there's a there's a a habit that has
been right that's so ingrained that it's
weird to do otherwise that's what we're
looking with the kids doesn't mean they
don't see me speak other languages with
other people doesn't mean I can't read
to them in a different language it means
that the the mode of communication
between myself and the kids is always in
Madrid and that's just
natural it's just a habit so for every
language we teach them we create that
environment where they have to do it so
Mandarin with me Japanese with mom who's
Japanese so that's a natural thing
living in Quebec go doing going to a
Quebec you know school that's French and
English through certain inputs by TV or
some in Anglophone friends around here
they're skating coach is in English my
daughter's you know horseback riding
coaches in English that that kind of
input and then we sometimes have
exchange students who speak English if
we have au pairs who speak English
sometimes in the fifth language is
Spanish in this we we have consistently
hired a pairs from Mexico so they always
have a person to with whom they need to
speak Spanish you know their caregivers
so that's where they have that
communication that's their their
language of the heart with that person
now a couple of comments or questions
here first of all I have heard your kids
not the most recent child
congratulations again but the other
speak these languages and they are truly
remarkably fluent and comfortable in
those languages they remind me of that
girl from Russia that we had at the long
face a couple years ago yes now and so
so both of her parents were essentially
if I remember correctly they were more
or less Union maybe the mum spoke
English but the dad spoke only Russian I
believe yes well their English is I mean
limited its yard so then the question is
and she was remarkable she spoke like
seven or eight languages very well yes
so my question I think a lot of people
at home are saying okay that's good for
you you have a Japanese speaking why if
you speak several languages your parents
speak several languages that's a rather
unique environment so what is your
average parent do who doesn't have those
advantages so my first my first remote
oh sorry about that we have 13 at 13
okay oops sorry about that I had my ball
game up okay my first rebuttal to that
is that your average parent is not
looking for five writers right bilingual
is good
the great majority is a second language
and and I think with the different
methods that we apply I mean just the
Spanish is something we brought in
completely artificial right and it's
working very well so so for a second
language you don't have to look at me
and say well you have a special
situation I'm not gonna deny we have a
special situation although it's not
completely you know it's not completely
dude right there's so many couples who
are who are in cross-cultural rider ages
and and we've made a choice to live in
Cabaye you know so these are things that
you can if you want to if you really
want to do it you can just to summarize
if you have two languages within your
marriage you are suggesting that that
you should get in the habit of each
parent speaking to their children or
child in one language all the time
almost yes well first yes if that's the
only yeah but if you are a if let's say
you're a French and Spanish couple
living in the Ukraine then I would
recommend yes each speak no in French
and Spanish and English and outside of
that's great so that would make a three
language relatively easily now if one
parent was actually an English who
speaks French that's right then since
they're living in the UK I would
recommend this parent to also speak
French to make the home language so this
is called minority language right
stronger so the French would have much
more exposure if the if the English
parent has a strong enough sorry
so that you have say the mum is say
Spanish or Chinese or something and the
dad is English living in London but the
dad speaks French so then the mom speaks
Chinese the dad speaks French and the
kid gets or the children get English in
the society yeah that's right that's
right so the community language is very
very strong so I I never worry about
it's what you you know it's the weaker
languages where you have less exposure
that I always try to balance out so in
our situation Mandarin is is one of our
weakest because I am the only input
along with my mother but no Japanese is
quite strong because they spent so much
time with mom and so I would say that
they're they're real strongest emotional
languages generally so when they have
when they have something that we really
need to express it with the in Germany's
when they talk to each other when
they're just the kids alone often it's
in Japanese so but okay but getting back
to the earlier point so it what if you
are you're living in the States
you're both American you both speak
English you both speak say one or say
between the two cup you know partners
there you have two languages that you
speak as non natives maybe you don't
speak them that well what are your
options okay it's all a matter of
mountains if you're not very strong but
you don't have too much on let's say
resources to hire a native speaker or or
send them to school or whatever then
your options are you do it you know
you've read the books to them and you
speak that language of them but you have
to figure out what the trade-offs that
you're willing to accept are you willing
to learn the language with the kids
yeah that's that's one option right
otherwise if you really think that they
did this language let's say it's Spanish
or if you really want them to speak
Spanish and you speak a relatively low
level of Spanish you don't want your
kids to to pick up all your anything I
would say hire a nanny speak Spanish all
right I'm gonna bring in an au pair or
exchange student who speaks Spanish you
know that that's that's sort of
alleviates the financial aspects so just
to pick up on that then what you're
saying is you really need a live speaker
who speaks the language well ideally a
native speaker failing that someone who
speaks the language
a live person to interact with the child
yes now there's a lot of controversy
over whether TV or you know videos
devices can allow your children to learn
languages I don't say no I definitely
think there's a there's a certain level
of input that you can get but there's a
lot of research that says you know you
need that live interaction and a lot of
that I think is the connection that you
make with you that emotional bribe that
allows you to really want to speak want
to communicate with that person so so I
can bring in I've had Mexican pairs who
were responsible for teaching Spanish
English to my kids their English is you
know it's good on a conversational level
but accent wise there's a little
medicine but I don't worry about that
too much because there's a lot of TV
that watch in English and it's and that
corrects their accent I mean
theoretically yeah it's not the agree a
small amount of somewhat accented
English in the massive amounts of input
that they get is gonna have no influence
yeah that's that's listen that's what I
would suggest because what you know I I
have a feeling we could talk for a long
long time on this yeah sometimes people
see a turning minute video on this well
I'm not gonna listen to this so we're
gonna stop it here and okay what I'm
gonna say is people who are interested
in this subject please send us your
questions
Tetsuo and I can do it again please also
go to ask tetes you'll see his the link
to his website and that's a YouTube
channel isn't it YouTube YouTube channel
and we should also perhaps if there's
interest we can have the same discussion
in Japanese and Chinese in French and
Spanish so all these possibilities are
there I but I wanted to sort of respond
to Ryan Jorgensen and get this subject
out there for my viewers and I'm looking
forward to your response and please ask
tetes anytime anytime go out there raise
the next global citizen for there we go
okay thank you very much bye bye thank
you Steve
[Music]